the morgue a dental facility a
sterilization building and therapeutics
clinic
all gone neurologist ilona boutiva says
of the 27 doctors who worked here before
the war
five remain
there were such cases when civilians
were brought in with great damage there
was heavy shelling and we provided help
in the corridor her reality is so
different from her dreams
this neurologist scrolling through her
phone to show me the application she
started a few years back to move to
canada to practice medicine
hospital staff have requested we not
name the town it's located in
[Music]
both soldiers and civilians are treated
here the hospital is dark the hallway is
small and there's little equipment to be
seen this is the hospital's bomb shelter
and it's only really used by the doctors
when it's absolutely necessary when the
shelling is very very close and very
loud it's not the most comfortable place
for doctors or patients but they've
actually operated on someone down here
shrapnel was pulled from a patient while
in the bunker cell phone video was taken
of the operation
phones were also used to provide the
doctors with some light to work
above ground on the top floor
it's the opposite problem
this room doesn't get used the windows
and all the natural light she explains
make the staff vulnerable to sniper fire
the injuries seen here are critical and
the volume of patients can be
overwhelming 10 wounded soldiers can
arrive at once all in dire need of
urgent care medical personnel from keeve
are now helping on site
our hospitals are not very well equipped
we bring a lot with us and volunteers
help us
around town you don't see many children
or open businesses just fortified
bunkers open fields and destruction the
hospital complex has been shelled at
least five times since february 24th
i have two daughters five and ten and
when it was dangerous here i put them on
an evacuation bus
separated from family and overworked the
war has been unrelenting for these
doctors who say everything they do is in
service of their country the hospital
has become home their work consuming
every minute of their day though global
news did witness a tiny reprieve
a little care for the caregiver with a
surprise visit from boutiva's husband
she hasn't seen him in months
crystal gomez in global news northern
heart cave region